Lindsay thanks for being here so excited
to have you here you know you've had
first of all I want to ask you about the
ESPYs because that is the award show for
all of sports is it fun for you to go to
the ESPYs is it like a fun event to see
all these athletes from different sports
that you don't ever get to interact with
all in one place or is it not that great
it's really fun it's really fun yeah I
don't know I'm just I'm kind of geeked
out sometimes I'm a big sports fan
obviously and right it's so nice to just
I don't know shoot the with the
other athletes man okay all right okay
you're clearly following Emma's example
and taking us down a very dark road with
your foul language well I think it would
be fun to see these people that are in
completely different sports you don't
get to see them do you guys joke around
with each other is there an air of like
not taking it too seriously oh I don't
take anything seriously yeah no I love
making fun of other athletes right
awesome like you really blew it at the
Super Bowl that must be that must be
really fun yeah yeah and then you just
ski away
hey see you later swoon you were up
against for Best Female Athlete you're
up against Ronda Rousey is that right
yeah I'm she's gonna she's gonna beat me
up you're really are you afraid I would
think if that's a category where you're
afraid to win yeah because we're up
against this amazing fighter who's just
unbeatable beats everybody in about ten
seconds and yeah you worried that what
if you what if you win in that category
exactly I feel like if I won I would be
concerned about her dislocated my elbow
backstage yeah just where Lindsey go yes
you just come at me so fast and then
you're you're up for best comeback
athlete as well yeah and you're up
against New England Patriots Rob
Gronkowski yeah and and he's kind of
cool you like him he's just he's pretty
good athlete so I'm a little bit nervous
about that category but you know I think
my injury was definitely a lot worse so
I think technically I should win that
yeah that's right you both
okay I love a crab cheering yay worse
injury that's right you were yeah you
were both you were both getting rehab on
your injuries in the same place at the
same time isn't that right yeah we were
at the doctor Andrews Institute and I
was a little I'm a little competitive
yeah I would think you would have to be
a little competitive there like who can
pedal the basses on the arm bike you
know like who can walk farther because
that's you know I'm like my main goal
was to walk you know five feet on my own
when I got my surgery and so I was like
I I won I beat you clearly I'm the best
here that's like I love someone post
surgery mocking another person Kosar
what else are you gonna do yeah recover
watch TV hey thanks for watching be sure
to click subscribe to see even more
great Conan clips you may now return to
your pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography